die klimakaoten sie machen weiter und
zwar heute beim Verkehrsministerium
attackiert von den klimakaoten mit ja
rotem betesaft auf die Bilder gut 40
Aktivisten sind hier am Werk von
scientest Rebellion sie blockieren die
Zugänge zum Ministerium kleben sich am
Asphalt fest und dann eine riesige rote
Beete lache was sie fordern das
Tempolimit und das 9-euro-ticket wieder
einzuführen scientist Rebellion das ist
ja sagen sie selber in Zusammenschluss
von internationalen Wissenschaftlern die
sofortige Maßnahmen gegen die Klimakrise
verlangen aber mit
Lebensmittelverschwendung haben sie
offenbar kein Problem so unsere Kollegin
Annika rasch die ist für uns vor Ort am
Verkehrsministerium Annika heute morgen
also dieser rote Beete Anschlag wie
sieht es denn jetzt aus
genau wir schalten am Schauen am besten
gleich mal hin wir drehen mal die Kamera
hier wird nämlich gerade drüben am
Verkehrsministerium fleißig geputzt im
Regen die am
Reinigungskräfte das sind ungefähr
sieben müssen hier gerade eben diesen
rote Beete Saft wieder von der Wand und
von dem Boden von den Fenstern lösen
denn die Woche ist hier mal wieder mit
Blockadeaktion der klimaaktivisten
gestartet gestern sind klimaaktivisten
ja ins Finanzministerium eingedrungen
heute haben dann 40 von ihnen eben hier
am Verteidigungsministerium mit rote
Beete Saft die Türen beschmiert wie ich
drehe mich einmal kurz zur Seite damit
ihr das seht also die Polizei nimmt hier
eben noch die Personalien auf die
klimaaktivisten hatten hier das Gebäude
bzw die Straßen um das Gebäude herum
blockiert und dann eben mit diesem rote
Beete Saft die Wände beschmiert aber
bisher werden eben nur die Personalien
aufgenommen
das heißt was passiert jetzt mit denen
müssen die damit rechnen dass sie jetzt
verhaftet werden für diese Aktion am
Verkehrsministerium
ja das ist immer eine Grauzone also oft
kommen diese klimaaktivisten dann für
diese Taten ja praktisch kommen sie
davon es gibt manchmal Geldstrafen aber
nur selten werden sie wirklich
verurteilt man muss aber wirklich sagen
dass die Proteste jetzt in den letzten
Tagen sich auch noch mal verschlimmert
haben wir haben das Anfang des Jahres
schon ab Februar gemerkt oder gesehen
dass viele Autobahnen Zufahrten
blockiert wurden von den klimaaktivisten
weil sie sich am Boden festgeklebt haben
jetzt wird es radikaler wir haben jetzt
vor ein paar Tagen in London gesehen wie
man mit Tomatensuppe ein Van
gogh-gemälde beschmiert hat und jetzt
eben hier vor dem
Verteidigungsministerium mit rote Beete
Saft auffällig ist auch wie gesagt dass
diese Woche allein schon zwei
Ministerien ja sozusagen
ins
attackiert wurden sozusagen von den
klimaaktivisten das heißt die Frage ist
natürlich diese Woche hat eben noch ein
paar Tage wie es diese die letzten Tage
weitergeht auch im Sinne der
Ministerien ob auch noch weitere zum
Ziel der klimaaktivisten werden da
kreativ sind sie ja die klimaaktivisten
Dankeschön Annika rasch
[Musik]